[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm link and I'm
Rhett this week at the well my tables
not round my table is a rectangle my
table is a big oval like I've got an
ellipse this is my dining room table
then I'm seated at in my own home I'm in
a corner of my living room at a table
that I actually I actually got upset
with my wife about buying this table
because she got like a nice table that
you have to like screw together in order
to as opposed to what well I can't leave
able the table that she got for a party
that has since been cancelled because of
the virus
my son's 16th birthday and because she
can't just have like a folding table
like everyone else she's got to have a
pretty wooden table that you have to put
together I was like why why do we have
this I know we have to put it together
but now I am so thankful to my beautiful
wife and my smart wife my wife we had so
much foresight she's not Jesse she's not
watching she's grown up she was she's
taking a shower right now if you know if
I must be if I must be honest about this
you must be honest because right before
we started recording I said okay guys I
started to record and no one responded
she said well I'm taking a shower and
then my my fifth-grade son it just
continued to he's talking to his
classmates he's learning they're
learning he's doing school we are in a
totally I mean this is the first thing
that has been completely altered because
of the virus for for us in terms of
content this is our this is the first
ever ear biscuits that we are performing
remotely separate from each other
performing I feel like I'm saying weird
word it's your present not I'm not in my
normal environment I would have just
said doing this is like dear biscuit
that we're doing I don't mean performing
in like a like a performance since like
in an inert
since like I mean performing in like a
Surgical sense because I'm gonna be
honest I'm a bit stressed out because I
mean we've got it's just me doing
everything on my own I don't know if
you've got assistance I don't think you
do you I'm gonna be I'm trying to I try
to get my children to help and they they
did not respond yeah so yeah I'm
performing a freaking technical feat
here that you know I'm freaking rusty
even I mean thinking as we've been doing
the vlogs I at least know how to work
our camera and now it's like I had to
dust off my GarageBand to figure out how
to record myself and then we got it just
sort of like video chatting with you
yeah like just to give you an idea of
how this is set up if you're that kind
of person is interested well first of
all let me just say that something will
go wrong and with this recording I mean
it it's just it is destined there's
destined destined to be an error
somewhere in the process and you're
probably gonna be somewhat frustrated
hopefully not but I'm pretty shocked
were three minutes in and nothing's gone
wrong except for my use of the word
performance and I also thought that this
would be a simpler process to set up I
was like oh no okay because we're gonna
do this thing where we're gonna do like
a split screen we'll talk about how
we're trying to figure out the same kind
of deal for gmm but essentially we've
got the camera that we normally record
the vlogs with recording video we've got
audio going directly into a computer we
both have these blue Yeti mics this one
I've had forever link had to get that
one so this is like one of our first
mics that we ever bought as a as a
company and yeah I actually saw a clip
of when we went back to harness central
moving back to our high school we shot I
think we shot a week's worth of episodes
from miss I can't remember whose room is
soul's room our old French class and
yeah you we had that microphone yeah so
those mics are going directly into our
laptops which are recording the audio on
GarageBand but then in order to be able
to communicate with each other at the
same time we are on a Google Chat
that's on an iPad that we are looking at
so I'm now looking at link who's looking
at me and if other members want to log
into the chat they can watch this as
it's happening but but yeah I mean we
here's what we want to do today we want
to process we want to bring you up to
speed on what our process has been as
we've settled into staying at home and
coming to grips with what this virus
means for us and what it means for our
our worlds and also the world in general
so this is you know I just want to pry I
want to process that with my friend here
on the I mean there's also this thing
that's like getting past the fact that
like hey we're communicating on screens
this is the new normal
a lot of communicating on screens will
get into all that but well because I
will say again we're recording this a
few days before the audio goes live but
a week and a half or so before almost
two weeks before it would go live video
on YouTube so a lot may have changed by
then but currently where we're at in
California we are under a stay at home
order so it is technically illegal at
this point for us to conduct our
business and the way that we typically
would ie going into the studio now I
think we want to protect ourselves we
want to we want to protect other people
we want to we want to do the right thing
so yeah we're not doing it just trying
to get out we're not not doing it just
because it's illegal we actually and
it's interesting at this point in the
conversation nationwide it's there's
very different perspectives there's
people who are like oh this is a
complete overreaction and there are
people who are like no we need to be
listening to what the medical experts
are telling us and we're on team medical
expert we're not medical experts but
we're on team
we believe the
medical experts the consensus of the
medical experts being that we need to
stay at home social distance and kind of
flatten the curve so this is our effort
to flatten the curve and so we're gonna
continue to bring you what we can bring
you it's just gonna be in a slightly
flattened the curve manner yeah I I
would I just want I want to hear this
story that I've heard like third hand I
want to hear it from your perspective
because you haven't told me Christy was
talking to Jesse and I caught bits and
pieces of she was she was shocked by by
someone outside of her window and I I
just didn't hear the full story I I want
to hear that from you right now well
yeah so our wives were on a group video
chat with their their close group of
female friends which they I don't think
they had ever done that I their own
they've been on WeChat for years that's
the thing that they would talk to each
other and give themselves cute little
chat group names or whatnot they were
well ahead of the curve of us finally
doing that with our friends but and they
never did video chats so it's like again
it's it it's just one example like I
said of of a new normal getting use of
this video chat group chat stuff but
anyway go ahead but one of the things
that has been an unfortunate just
coincidence is that it's been raining
like crazy in California I mean yeah we
got it we got to deal with this virus we
got to stay at home but that doesn't
mean you got to stay in your house in
fact we've been trying to take advantage
of being together as a family and hiking
and walking Barbara's gotten more walks
and she's like what are we doing what is
this and by the way part part trails are
now closed as of yesterday you can't go
on a trail well I didn't tell you this
but on Saturday and this is why they're
closed because on Saturday Jesse and I
were like hey let's go up to the local
trail yeah to kind of get up in
in there and as soon as we pull them
trailhead as soon as we pull into the
place the cars are parked on the street
so you know that all the parking lots
are overflowed and they're not in these
trails or these trails are not wide
there and so here oh we we drove right
through and drove right out because I
was like hey boys and girls that's not
social distancing I mean just because
you're outside doesn't mean the virus
isn't like I'm outside and so therefore
I can't move if somebody coughs on you a
breeze on you on you're on the trail and
you like you're you're even hee-hee and
in hell is it even in heaven huffin even
in heaven well i yeah i before the
governor put in the stay at home
provision we had already decided that we
were gonna you know both of our families
we decided we were gonna hunker down in
our own homes and send our employees
home and everything but it was the first
day that it hadn't rained and again it
was before that ordinance was in place
and I said well we can we can just go on
some trails and then we were on the
trail and there was about as many people
as normal but then yeah the huffing and
puffing like people would come down the
trail and I would stand to the side and
face away and but I was self-conscious
because again this is pretty early a lot
of people I think we're just on the
trail because it's part of their normal
lives just to go on this trail and like
run up and down it or take the dog or if
they're an old person with the two
sticks lots of those old people with two
sticks we're still out there at that
point
yeah and so I would like act instead of
just like hmm just like what's the call
when you pull back in your that's a he
never okay but that's the heave of the
heave enough now I think that's
acceptable of course you can't go on
trails but then I would like I would
turn and I would act like I was taking
in the view you know like it's beautiful
out here
but just to like turn away from people
who were huffing and puffing and going
by well what I've been doing as if I
haven't been on a trail yet and
apparently I'm not ever going to be
again when we've been walking around the
neighborhood and we've seen people
coming you know me I can hold my breath
for a long time so when they get about
25-30 steps away I just hold my breath
and then I go by and then I release you
start turning blue if they what if they
stop and talk to you you're like I just
give a head nod mm-hmm actually I can
talk and I can talk and not breathe in
yep
are you doing I haven't taken a breath
yet yep I'm still breathing out that
series going up you know what I could
breathe in I cannot really talk I'm not
I'm not you actually don't have to
change the way that you talk I don't
know what we're doing that no hold on
take a deep breath and then if I just
talk no I'm breathing out you got to
breathe out to talk but talking is
breathing out because then you're
sucking in other people's virus yeah I'm
just using that as an example but I'm
just yeah but you can't breathe back in
so it's just breathing out but you never
take a breath back in so whenever you
stop talking you're holding your breath
again and that is not absolutely normal
right
anyway but where I was going with that
was I haven't had an opportunity to go
outside very much because it's been
raining so much yeah I think this is our
last week of crazy rain and then it's
gonna get back to more like Southern
California but there was a moment of
sunshine
it wasn't very warm I mean for
California was like 55 degrees which we
were still like oh that's a jacket it's
like a blizzard to me but because the
Sun came out I went outside and actually
took my shirt off got down just to my
pants and took my meditation cushion out
there
and started doing some yoga I did some
meditation I mean I just became like a
amateur guru out there on my basketball
area out here and amateur guru is not a
thing those like can't those words
cancel each other out that's what I
think is wanna be Guru sure I don't
think you want to be guru and I think at
this point just sidebar my
air-conditioner heater came on it's boy
there's gonna be a lot of noise in this
in this podcast just get over it no one
hears I'm not gonna probably word again
everybody was over it so I am I was out
there first of all I was just enjoying
myself just beyond words and you know
I've gotten really flexible have you
seen how flexible I am now no I know
I've been moving around like a real old
man and all our vlogs we could it's
because of my knee but my knee is
basically healed
I mean took almost two months for my
knee to get healed so I'm kind of back
to my spry self now okay and just in
time to do nothing yeah
exactly just in time to stay at home but
I was doing all kinds of I got I was
going on the internet looking at moves
doing them but then I just started to
kind of walk around out there and just
you know just take in the Sun and then I
realized that oh I just walked up to the
window to the guest bedroom which is
where jesse is currently on her lady's
Chet ah so what was she hasn't told me
about this by the way she told Christie
that some she saw someone walked by and
she thought it was a shirtless vagrant
like her her emotional and knee-jerk
reaction was fear yeah she was deeply
afraid because her husband walked past
the window and then it took her a couple
of beats and she was like wait
that was my husband what what have you
done man I mean like you well yeah we'll
say Gallivan around your house and
you're you're putting your own family in
fear well yesterday this knows something
the other day I was walking through the
neighborhood just by myself shirtless
and no I I was but I mean I didn't look
well kept no because oh you don't right
and I had on like I had on a hoodie and
then like some unmatching sweatpants and
like hiking shoes okay that's because
because it was a day we thought we were
gonna go to the to the trail yeah and I
know what my I listen I I've seen the
comments I've seen all the people
requesting beard or hair trims at this
point it's definitely not gonna happen
it's like I feel like I was I've been
preparing for this moment all my life to
look like this during this pandemic you
were ahead of the curve but I was
walking through the neighborhood and I
started realizing that it could easily
be perceived that a homeless man has
left some urban area and has now up into
the neighborhoods looking for a place to
bed down his territory has expanded and
I got a little paranoid and oh you got
paranoid and then all of a sudden like
at the height of my paranoia I hear like
a you know like when the cops did that
thing where they had a turtle noise the
carpet up sharped you I turn around and
there's a cop like flying towards me
with his with this lights on and the
siren now he's chirping he's he's like
he's like it almost like a record
scratch with a chirp and I'm like
somebody has called and said that
there's a vagrant walking through the
neighborhood and this play your wife in
the cop is is coming after me yeah it
got down put your hand behind you
but I was thinking about like what I was
gonna say I was like nah I live here
it's like and I was realizing that no
matter what I said everything was gonna
sound made-up I haven't been cutting my
hair because of therapy it's a long
story
I was actually thinking about this today
that even if I made a decision to trim
I'm not gonna cut my own hair at this
point yeah well you could I'm not saying
you could I'm not saying you couldn't
I'm saying you shouldn't but but just to
just you know to check in on that I
don't feel like I've I don't feel like
I've learned my lesson yet you know I'm
saying I you know I think I'm like yeah
your business is the reason I think you
know I don't think I've I don't think
I've learned what I need to learn yet
I've learned that people a lot of people
have I learned that it's polarizing
that's what I've learned as well I think
you also have learned like keep a shirt
on whenever possible stay off the
streets try to get your sweat suit to
mat match if you're going out in public
just do a little something do a little
something for yourself you know we got
good I actually have some thoughts about
self-care in this environment I'll get
to a little bit later but for right now
let's plug the store okay
mythical calm yeah oh they're fully we
still selling stuff we just released a
new I am a mythical beast tea so check
that out yes actually yeah we're the
proceeds a portion of the proceeds from
the the sale of the be your mythical
best in 3d tea are going to feeding
America a nationwide network of 200 food
banks working to ensure our most
vulnerable populations continue to have
access to food students who are out of
school the elderly individuals whose
jobs are impacted in low-income families
the feeding America Food Bank network is
committed to serving communities and
people facing hunger in America during
the Cova denied team pandemic find out
what they are doing and how you can help
at feeding America org did you memorize
all that that's great yeah yeah yeah I
was a reading that was really great I've
had I've had a lot of time
a lot of it you're devoting all of this
extra time to like memorization right I
mean that is an idea if you got you know
there there's time we can we can invest
in ourselves a little bit rep your boys
help a good cause be your mythical best
by wearing the mythical best tea it's
also the feel-good stuff I mean
everybody wants to feel good in its time
we got we're selling some stuff mythical
dot-com to help you feel good physically
in your body
mythical dots come oh it's a mythical
Dutch story
mythical dot-com I just really like to
process what's happened over the last
few weeks just like how what what I'm
curious what your experience has been
and I just figured we could share our
experiences because it's it's it's just
been so surreal there's so many times
when I'm like this is I'm it's like a
movie you know it's like this this
doesn't really happen
I've noticed that that thought has
started to happen less and less but for
the for the first week and a half or so
like every night when I lay down in the
bed it was just like I take a breath
that would be the main thing that I
would feel is like it's this real you
know as we were getting pummeled with
news every few minutes was something was
changing every everyone in every sector
of society was just scrambling to figure
out what to do and having the entire
spectrum of reactions I think the one
moment that will stick with me is let's
see it was a couple of weeks ago before
things got really stringent here again
we we were trying to be as safe as
possible and we were preparing to send
employees home this is Wednesday a
couple of weeks ago and then just
getting them prepared like hey Friday
get your stuff don't come in and then I
think the announcement went out
officially that Sunday
so I'm not saying hey we were ahead of
the curve but I mean we were we were we
were sending people home we were
starting to process but I had not
watched the news I had read the news in
you know I'd read like the the bytes of
news but we were in a very busy time we
were actually recording a lot of GMM you
know and thank goodness we recorded as
much as we were able to record to then
have a fully produced set based episodes
that we could stretch out but I'd not
consumed live television news because
it's just not it's not a part of my life
anymore you know I I just don't like the
bickering I don't I don't it's nothing
but stress and it just ticks me off but
I was like hey we got it we got to do
this so I turned it on I think this is
like Wednesday or Thursday night but
almost look at here's a lot of room door
closed oh I didn't get any quieter it's
okay go ahead link it's fine for what
it's worth I can't hear your call here
because you're listening to a video chat
which is not good right get it but that
- in this we shouldn't have started
running the washing machine but it's
fine we you mean I mean my beautiful
wife oh gosh go go
you finished getting ready nothing okay
yeah you don't watch news and I watch
the news about you know not about you
for many years when we would get to work
and I'd be like so did you hear about
so-and-so but that I changed that that
recently did change because you got
instantly over the past over the past
year I every day I will read the not the
headlines on my phone I will read the
headline when you've been friend
somebody turnover when you've been
friends with somebody for over 35 years
recently is in the past year just okay
what I mean that's not what recently
sound likes everybody else you know so I
turn on the news and it was it was it's
a different experience watching
television news and
about it and it it really that's when it
really hit me I mean the newscaster
looked straight down the lens and said
we need to come to grips with this you
need to come to grips with this this is
the new normal for the foreseeable
future if you were used to getting what
we want when we want it and that's not
going to be the case Jake Chula I think
she's getting worked up because she
thinks I'm getting worked up because I'm
channeling my inner newscaster what are
you buddy barking at
do you hear rats laundry it's okay
and I gathered the kids around and
because Chrissy and I were watching it
and I said you know what kids this is I
just want you to know this is a huge
deal what we're gonna be as safe as
possible I tried I gave them reassurance
but then I also said this is something
that you're gonna remember for the rest
of your life hey am I gonna have to send
you away and you know what I mean by
that I just mean go in another room and
sit on another comfy couch the last time
I remember hanging on the words of a
newscaster was 9/11 and I know that I
think it was the governor of New York
it may have been thrown out thrown
around by a bunch of people that like
this is this is this generations 9/11 in
the sense that my experience theme the
the all of the questions all of the the
fear that came up all of the just not
knowing how to process it and looking
for someone or the people who can help
make sense of it to give reassurance
that there's a plan that there's that
we're going to be okay and I distinctly
remember that morning a lion 911 just
hanging on every word of the newscasters
and everyone was trying to figure it out
on live television you know and again
this is much this is more drawn-out than
that and it it's different in a bunch of
ways but there was a kindred experience
that then I tried to convey to the kids
but I I just ended up saying you're
gonna remember this the rest of your
lives having to having to hunker down in
our homes and you know I didn't make it
I didn't make it that bleak in doom and
gloom as as scared as I was I didn't
want to I didn't want to dump all that
on them so I didn't do it but yeah well
you know an interesting thing you know a
I would say two things kind of where I
come from a slightly different place
with this I mean one my talk about the
you know apocalypse is III don't often
talk about it in you know I'm joking I'm
going into character and I'm just kind
of biessing but that comes from a place
of actual concern that you know all our
systems are so fragile we're seeing that
right now we're seeing that the we were
a lot more vulnerable and a lot more
ways than anybody well I'm gonna say
than anybody knew but actually there's a
lot of people who've been saying for
years you know the again I think I think
people who aren't in America might be a
little bit perplexed as to what they
hear coming out of the US and they see
on Twitter and they see on the news it's
like why is there this very bifurcated
reaction to what's what's happening and
why does it seem like people of a
particular political persuasion seem to
think a certain way about a virus I
think that's probably rather perplexing
to people from other places in the world
and there's there's a lot of reasons
that go behind that but I think that
interestingly we have seen a lot of
people saying hey guys listen this is
going to happen you see a lot of people
saying like nobody could bit have been
prepared for this well actually there's
like there's some excellent books that
have been written about this that
basically said that this was completely
and totally inevitable unavoidable
predictable they've been telling us for
years that given how global our society
is now and how quickly people travel how
easy it is for you know a virus to jump
from an animal to a person and there be
no it no community anyway we kind of
knew that this was gonna happen and so I
think I kind of had in the in the many
different in in time scenarios that when
you watch like Doomsday Preppers and
that kind of thing and again I don't
think that we're not in an apocalyptic
situation by any means is this is not
the end of culture or humanity or
anything this is just a difficult thing
that is affecting everybody and that we
have to kind of come together and
overcome and we will overcome it's just
a matter of how long will it take but
but you're the but you're the type of
person that was familiar with the world
of the world going into crisis because
you you have an interest in it because
there's something because of your
personality type there's something
within you they that made you read about
it but then there's a second step it's
like when you would read about these
things you would process them in a way
that led to personal application like in
I think it was the GMM episode what you
went through all the all the apocalypse
bunker stuff that you had bought and you
took me through it and then you you also
bought stuff from me right and we made
it which hopefully you still have I
still have I haven't had to dig into it
yet but I feel better knowing I have it
so thank you once again but yeah I think
we represent two different personality
types that like and I and I think mine's
a little bit different and but go ahead
well so yeah this was something that
wasn't a surprise to me right but the
second thing was
we have the news on all the time like it
is a it's kind of like a you know we've
got the news on in the house like at
night a couple three times a times a
week I think our kids our kids get very
tired of hearing me and Jesse talk about
the news
whereas with Lando when I sat him down
and we were watching the news that night
it was the first time we had ever
watched there's his family and he was
the newscaster was interviewing somebody
and they were getting into it you know
like they do it was just like they were
trying to cut each other off and one guy
wanted answer his say what he wanted to
say instead of the quote answer the
question and Lando
turned to me and he said are they angry
with each other they are they fighting
and I was like yeah that's that's what
happens on the news which was news to
him and it again it's like that's not my
vibe man it's just like well I gotta
watch the Australian news but I think
that's one of the interesting elements
of this thing is that you know because
the because the whole world of news both
online print and cable news everything
is driven by ad revenue right and so for
years we've gotten into this place where
it seems like every time you come back
from a break on a on a cable news
program breaking news
right and I think when things actually
become breaking news like they have
right now when people actually need to
know like it's a potential life-or-death
situation whether or not they get this
information
I think people maybe become a little bit
numb to like oh yeah you guys are
panicking about something I think that's
one of the things that's happened in our
country a lot of people who are like
they're always talking about the latest
crisis they're always talking about how
things are falling apart but it's like
does it ever really happen and so I
think that people are skeptical of that
you've even got like the NatGeo shows
like the seven ways that the world will
end and let's spend sixty minutes on
each one you know and
that's just not the type of stuff I like
to watch that you'd like to watch that
type of stuff because I don't want to I
would rather think and on a subconscious
level it's been easy for me to think you
know what the scientists or experts and
whatever field it is they have to be
alarmist in order to be heard you've got
a you've got to be your own hype man if
you want anybody to listen to you and it
was it was a convenient position
subconsciously for me to to settle into
but I will say turning on the news and
experiencing the breaking news for the
first time because I was out of that
world I woke up like I mean I was
texting you that night I was like what
what does this mean for our friends our
families for our company and in terms of
action we need to take you were already
talking about that so I felt like I kind
of got on board so and then there's
people who are said you know it everyone
is had to sink in for everyone in their
own time and that's the difficulty
because in the meantime this virus is
moving around but I think I did get on
board and I think you were like what was
there any part of you that there was
like I'll call it a morbid excitement
like yes this is I mean I don't want to
frame you here maybe that's an maybe
that's a nasty question well I think
that I do think actually I think it's
it's helpful sometimes because I mean
I'll talk in a second about like what
I'm actually fearful of and like what
I'm anxious about like how that how I've
been dealing with that personally but to
me I find it helpful like when I'm going
through something that would otherwise
be fear inducing you kind of think about
to think about being in the midst of a
story that has a happy ending right to
think about what role you're playing in
just larger adventure of humanity kind
of coming together and overcoming this
thing
so there is a there is um you know I
don't want to talk about it now because
I think there's a whole other podcast
and talking about why this is this could
ultimately be good for Humanity you know
like experiencing a crisis like this and
we could talk about all the things that
might change and for the better but I
know you've been watching Lord of the
Rings as well right that's right yeah so
as a family you know we everybody in the
family's already seen the movies but
it's been a while and so far we've just
watched the Fellowship of the Ring in
the two towers we haven't watched a
Return of the King yet but you had to be
thinking the same thing that I was
thinking multiple times during the in
this this could be my wreck but I have
another wreck but I'll make a mid
podcast wreck of watching The Lord of
the Rings because first of all like you
said you remember how much better it is
in The Hobbit right like The Hobbit was
an it was a great book but the
translation to three movies it just
didn't the Lord of the Rings is just is
some of it one is it's it's my favorite
trilogy okay that I'm on this is my
favorite trilogy and when I was watching
I was like this is better than Star Wars
I like told and Lily still won you know
I've always thought that I've always
thought that but like I'd forgotten it
was nice to get back into it look I
don't yeah it was I don't I don't weep
while watching Star Wars like I like
there's so many moments of just pure joy
and sadness and I anyway yeah but
there's these things that Frodo and Sam
especially and Gandalf they kind of say
to each other that are these epic
inspirational phrases there's these
conversations that they have where they
start realizing in fact is it at the end
of the Fellowship of the Ring or is it
two towers where I think it's in two
towers where Sam starts talking about
they're gonna tell are they gonna tell
stories about us you know I think I
think that might be the end of the first
movie yeah but it's like are we gonna be
the heroes
the story and I'm not and so right I
like to think about situations like this
not like how am I going to be a hero but
like how are we as a species going to
overcome this and like what's the story
that we're gonna tell and I hope the
story that we tell isn't that we started
not trusting one another and we just
were completely polarized like this is
an opportunity to come together again I
do think it requires people to actually
sort of digest what the real threat is
and I think that yeah even by the time
this podcast comes out that many more
people will be like oh okay this oh this
is serious but yeah so I do think
there's a part of me feels like gleaning
lots of hope from watching the movies
like the hope that drove Sam and Frodo
on their journey and that drove everyone
else to do whatever they could even when
they couldn't help
Frodo directly anymore they could help
out their friends they could they could
help out those that were that they were
with yeah and and or they kid and said
okay we can't go after them but we can
go after Merry and Pippin you know it
was I in it it hit me at such a at a
point where I really needed it just I
don't think I've ever gleaned so much
hope from watching a movie that applied
directly to it it just kind of fueled my
my ability to yeah and I don't the next
day I think that's a positive it's good
for us you know it's like yeah it's like
that's the kind of stuff that those are
the kind of challenges that we need to
face that we need to come together and
face I mean specifically the way that I
kind of been responding to it in terms
of how this the virus kind of taps into
my hypochondria okay has been
interesting even though you know I know
from a statistical standpoint the
majority of people who get it won't even
know they have it and then on top of
that
a larger majority of people who get it
will not require hospitalization you
know and within our age group with no
underlying health conditions again
statistically we're probably gonna be
okay even if we contract this thing
right but you hear those stories right
like I think a lot of the stories that
we're hearing and and I think that these
are getting more attention because
they're surprising it's like Oh 31 year
old Olympic gold medalist swimmer just
you know dealt with this for two weeks
and is still still feeling the effects
or 34 year old dude in LA dies from from
Kovan 19 so there's a part of me that I
mean of course I'm thinking about my
parents who are at who are in the
high-risk group your parents you know
we're we know a lot of people who are in
high-risk groups and so both of my
grandmother's yeah you still got
grandparents who were alive in their
90's so thinking about them but then I
started thinking like do I have a dry
cough you know is I'll start thinking do
it do my lungs feel funny like that's
how my hypochondria kind of manifests
itself and I started thinking that if I
have I have I contracted this Oh what am
I gonna be one of the statistics so I
kind of get on a little bit of a fear
loop spiral it's part of doing that and
then and it hasn't helped that I've also
I think I already knew I was slightly
allergic to dogs like when I got my
allergy test a couple years ago the only
thing that came up was a slight allergy
to dogs and cats but it was like a 2 out
of 5 or something
look Ovid 19 does not give you an
allergic reaction to dogs right but
because I am now at home with Barbara a
lot spending a lot of time with Barbara
it's like I've had this drainage and
like sore throat that's been going on
like two weeks now and I'm reasonably
certain
it's just that it's covered 19 that is
that's what I thought even though those
are not really symptoms of copán 19 for
most people so up until like yesterday
when it hit me I was like oh this might
be because me and Barbara are having so
much quality time which I've really
enjoyed all my quality time with Barbara
I don't know I'm gonna do about that I
might have to get a better allergy
medication
but anyway so these you could shave her
bald I thought you're gonna say
something else and I was gonna say it
she's a female dog bald he's like you
know where that you know where that were
the allergens come from they come from
the scrotum of the dog the hair on the
scrotum but my wife has the exact
opposite issue and she thinks that she's
going to give it to someone right okay
so I'm worried about getting it she's
worrying about giving it so I don't make
you feel better right that she's not
gonna give it to you well I don't think
she's worried about you she wearing a
mask everywhere no no okay
but as you know I do have masks because
that was one of the things that I had
already bought many years ago but I
don't have many I have like a couple of
packages of them but we actually because
we'd you know if you don't need them
unless you're sick technically we were
gonna have just a couple for ourselves
so it's you know if you haven't in 95
masks it can't offer some protection if
you if it's sealed correctly which is
pretty hard to do with a beard like this
like if you're gonna go into a grocery
store and you want to be extra safe it's
not gonna hurt to wear a mask but you
know Jesse's like hey we need to take
these masks to the hospital so she's
like already talking to this person on
Twitter who this is like three four days
ago and again this is two weeks out from
when you're gonna see this episode but
in Santa Monica
there was an ER doctor who was already
saying we're running out of masks I will
drive anywhere in LA to pick them up I
don't care how many you have and so she
was like talking to this person on
Twitter but at the time she had had a
sore throat and she was like I just want
to let you know
full disclosure I have a sore throat and
a woman is like okay wait 14 days anyway
we're gonna give our mass due to a
hospital as you should if you have some
if you one of the people that like me
had had some ahead of time I think for
me it's you know I just I don't obsess
about if I have it or not I feel like
that from for over a week now already
we've been we've been isolated we've
been very strict about it so I'm with
every day I'm gaining more confidence
that we're not carrying it and that
we're being that we're doing everything
in our power to be to protect ourselves
and other people at the same time so for
me it's it's more about channeling my
energies into a routine really routine
the things that I know like I'm gonna do
this and I'm gonna do this I'm gonna do
this I'm gonna fill my day with things
I'm gonna I'm gonna occupy myself and I
mean what as we've been developing what
our work plan is that that's certainly
helped but before we really got on top
of that there were a few days there
where it was just like a lot of cleaning
you know yesterday I went in I always go
into my shower and as I said in that
you're not showering properly gmm
episode or whatever it's titled we
changed the title so much I will clean
the drain of the shower because there's
so much freaking hair that gets in there
I don't know how my wife has any on her
head anymore honestly it might rip my
shower won't drain unless I clean even
less I cleaned the hair out of it and
I'm blaming it all on her because she's
not currently here her and her and
literally just walked out to take a walk
or something but the way my shower works
it's like this fancy long heavy strip of
tile that's like a it's like a a 1 inch
tall 2 inch wide 4 inch deep like slab
that you have to pull out and the
because the it looks it looks fancy all
right you can't see the drain and then
the water drains all in it and when you
pull out this big
in rectangular slab there's there's one
little drain at the end just one silver
dollar drain with like a thing on it but
that whole trough is plastic and it
fills up with like soap gunk and so here
I am for the first time ever not just
cleaning the hair out of the drain but
I'm getting down on all fours and I'm
spraying stuff down I'm grabbing a hand
towel and I'm cleaning out the trough of
this thing felt good
it didn't feel necessary but it felt
very good and I even though I totally
destroyed my hand towel with bleach it's
like a pink mosaic now that's nice
yeah it's pretty ugly we've been doing a
lot of cleaning and getting to getting
to things that just over time they like
the area next in my bed like my bedside
table and then like I like stacked books
and electronic equipment and stuff and
it just slowly and my wife calls it like
my corner yeah she's like what are you
gonna clean you have one at the office
too and I'm like well when I have time
is it's not important it's not important
to clean the corner well the corner is
cleaned
Corner is very clean right now I mean
you could sit him I take up before and
after photo no I don't do that kind of
thing I don't need I don't need to
congratulate myself with pictures you
know what I'm not gonna take that
because it's your loss that you don't
want to stop and celebrate your own
accomplishments I don't want to become
addicted to it well that of course that
doesn't happen who's who's addicted to
clean organizations a Glee who finds
themselves trapped by their own
processes right no woman the thing that
the thing that I've been thinking you
know so we have been you know from a
both personal and professional
standpoint this has been business
shaking things up change things around
right so I mean completely really my
heart goes out to
the many people whose businesses all
right
just completely stopped because of this
you know and I and I understand that
that's that's one of the big national
debates happening right now it's like
okay well and we can talk a little bit
more about this maybe in a subsequent
podcast about like the you know weighing
the value of the economy versus the
number of deaths which to me seems like
sort of a weird thing to to weigh but I
understand that like a complete
depression economic depression will harm
people and make people it will lead to
ultimately more death in some way so it
is a factor and I'm sensitive to the
people who who you know they don't have
any way to make any money right now
we're in a position where we can still
bring content to people even if it's
slightly altered like this but assuming
that the ad market is still going to be
somewhat is going to exist on some level
you know we still are in a service
business that we're offering a service
that we think is helpful at this time
and so we're committed to doing it but
thankfully we're in a position where we
can do that and we can keep our
employees employed and that kind of
thing and not everybody is in that
position so we recognize that we're in a
privileged position do that but that
that is our mentality yeah I think you
know the conversations we've been having
are I think that the word opportunity
comes up a lot I think and when we talk
to our team we're trying to convey that
to them as well that you know let's look
at let's be as smart as we can let's be
as safe as we can let's and then within
that context let's look at the things
that we can actually do the things that
we have control over and let's look for
as many opportunities that this
extremely challenging and scary
situation grants us because we can still
make videos it's an opportunity for us
to do that as an you know I think the
main opportunities are not capitalized
on anything
I mean opportunity in the sense of
service an opportunity to serve
our immediate families because we're
spending so much time together our our
friends and loved ones via phone calls
and chats our serving our mythical team
some of which we can give work to others
or don't have as much to do from home
because of the nature of what they were
doing at mythical they there's just
little for them to do at home but giving
them an assurance that hey we're gonna
keep putting out content in the most
creative way we can in order to continue
to support all of all of our team and to
keep them on the payroll just to just to
be blunt about it but also to create
content as a way to an opportunity to
serve all the mythical beasts to serve
you because I mean we're continuously
blown away with the opportunity we have
to make things that that connect with
you we talk about we come back to it a
lot on this podcast that like it's an
amazing privilege to be able to create
something that's the source of light in
your life and when we're when we all
everybody on earth is experiencing some
level of shadow being cast by this virus
over their lives some of them it feels
like a complete eclipse and if they're a
mythical beast we and we can give them
15 minutes 25 minutes with good mythical
more every single weekday if we can give
them of life we can give them these
conversations like it's a it's a
privilege to be able to do that and it's
exciting to know that we can do it you
know it's it's very engaging for me to
say you know I can make this not just
from it's not for not it's not about the
business it's not about the money except
in supporting our our team
in our families well we've talked about
it but it's about supporting the
mythical beasts yeah you know you know
one of the things that we have just
realized over the years is that you know
we never set out to do anything except
create right we never we were even years
ago we just were like okay we're just
gonna make video oh there's an audience
here and then people started talking
about the effect that the regular
content coming into their homes had on
them people helping people get through
things and again we were I think for
many years I always felt really
self-conscious and kind of uneasy about
that because I was like well that's not
what we're that's not what we're trying
to that's not what we're trying to do
we're just trying to make you laugh but
eventually I kind of just accepted the
reality that making people laugh is this
therapeutic it's good it's like I got to
embrace that that this is helpful and I
think that in a moment like this when
you can't do anything except in cuz
consume content for some people you're
in a situation where it's like okay well
I can clean I can work out I can take a
hike I commit myself food but really a
lot of us are just consuming content
reading books listen to the podcast
we're watching Internet videos watching
movies and those are yeah it's an
opportunity and it's an it's an
opportunity that we take very seriously
so it's you know we're we're completely
committed
just like link said we're completely
committed to continuing to bring you the
content that we have always brought you
it's gonna look a little bit different
of course and we'll be talking about how
that's gonna affect GMM and some other
things and hopefully this is not too
long of a period of time and we'll get
back to somewhat normal schedule soon
but our intention is that we recognize
that this is something that people kind
of count on especially during this time
and we want to not just for the sake of
our business and our come
any kind of remaining buoyant but also
to serve you guys I mean the kind of the
additional thing that I've been thinking
is again in that I'm trying to evaluate
whether or not like what part of this
comes from a healthy place and what part
comes from my sort of my own personal
struggles with being so
performance-based kind of having that
mindset of always wanting to do doo doo
and finding my self-worth and what I do
mm-hmm
you know I've seen this virus a lot of
people are taking advantage of this time
to not only do things for people but to
do things that are super cool and get
them noticed right and sometimes I
started thinking like okay all right
yeah we've got GMM that's great but
we've always had that we got your
biscuits that's great what we've always
had that you know we've got the mythical
kitchen stuff that we recently added to
the mix and all this stuff but I start
feeling this pressure to be like but
what else could we do you know you know
and I think that some of that could be
and I also feel it from a personal
standpoint which is like oh you've got
to all this time on your hands well you
know what you should like really figure
yourself out you know you this is an
opportunity to really accelerate those
that work you've been doing in therapy
and you need to like this is when you
need to really sit down and figure out
what your values are your goals and all
this stuff and the things that you keep
putting off kind of like getting your
mind straight about this stuff and so
yeah I felt this sort of intense
pressure
I've actually been overwhelmed by it a
couple of times and and I've had you
know I've felt myself like waking up in
the middle of night thinking about what
am I gonna do what are we gonna do what
are we gonna do to take advantage of
this not in a like slimy like get more
attention kind of way but it's just like
you know being in this sort of desperate
desperate times but being in a position
where we can bring people stuff
feeling this pressure to be like and
what else could we do and what else
could I do for my you know to deal with
myself and all that problems that I have
yeah I mean for me until like recording
this podcast is a relief for me because
I now know that we're wrapping up and we
actually got one in the can and were
able to do it I mean we're gonna record
a the first good mythical morning split
screen ever in a few hours I'll feel
much better but yesterday I was
completely overwhelmed setting up all
the technical aspects and I just felt
very buried so I I didn't have the
margin to think that much about those
things but I definitely understand I I
think the I wanted to read a quote from
an article that I think speaks directly
to this and also hopefully can serve as
encouragement to to you listening to I
was mean you know a Washington Post
article which came across Twitter and in
that article which I'm sorry camera what
it's called but as a rabbi rabbi yosef
was quoted from his Facebook page where
he had written to his LA congregation
but then it was put in The Washington
Post article and it had an impact on me
in terms of my mindset he said every
hand that we don't shake must become a
phone call that we place every embrace
that we avoid must become a verbal
expression of warmth and concern every
inch and every foot that we physically
place between ourselves and another must
become a thought as to how we might help
that other should the neither need arise
so yeah I think that this morning you
know I was in an effort to keep my
routine going and to start my day with
some sanity you know I've been trying to
do my workouts in the garage and this
morning I was I was halfway through it
and this golden retriever just runs up
into my garage
and then it ran back i petted the golden
tree verrat ran back out and then this
this woman who's a neighbor that i see
but never talked to is walking by and I
take the earbud out and we had a
conversation you know and it was a from
today how are you doing but yeah from
from 10 feet away and I was like oh my
maybe I shouldn't have touched her dog
I'd only petted once but I'm not gonna
sit here and like you know vopo new dog
but we had a we had there was a it was a
friendly conversation it was short but
there was an undertone of care that I
gave and received that was extremely
powerful that I never and it was it was
simple it was this is this is so surreal
isn't it do you have everything you need
it's actually a beautiful morning and
then that was it you know but there was
a connection that otherwise would never
have been made and I drew strength from
giving that care and also receiving it
and I think it's it doesn't have to be
the big things it can be this it can be
those small interactions you know it can
be you know I think about all the
opportunities that I have within my own
home with my family the amount of time
that we're spending together is utterly
unprecedented you know and there's a lot
of pitfalls associated that I'm sure
we'll get in all that later we need to
wrap up for the sake of uploading this
huge freaking file but I just wanted to
leave it at that quote yeah I think you
know we're gonna see I think we are
seeing we're seeing the best and the
worst in people right now you know there
are people who are thinking about
themselves people hoarding you know
people buying up things people price
gouging but I think that the the
majority of people are thinking about
their fellow person and I said I have
hope I have hope that in the end this is
this is gonna bring us together even
though we are especially in this country
divided Eva ghin like I said even even
about our perspective on a virus which
the virus has no political affiliation
you know the the virus doesn't care
about whether you're in a red state or a
blue state but still for some reason we
just we're so polarizing this country
that we filter everything through that
we can't hear a piece of news without
filtering it through the source but I
think that this is it's an unprecedented
situation but it's an unprecedented
opportunity to think about what you can
do for your fellow human I would say
love to love yourself and to love others
yeah okay I think this will I think this
one okay I think it went well
you got a wreck though yeah I do now
I've been telling you about this you
haven't responded to me about this yet I
know what to confer STUV all I will say
you do need to watch Lord a Lord of the
Rings do that but that's clear you got
to watch Tiger King on Netflix
everyone's been talking about this but
you've probably many of you probably
already watched it you've heard about
people talking about it and it's not for
everybody let me just say that it's not
for every time it's the documentary it's
a docu-series
about a not just one guy the tiger King
is just a dude who like raises Tigers
you know and like a sketchy situation
like the whole like home zoo and exotic
animals and that kind of thing but it's
the right it's the world of the that guy
and then other people like him but it's
also kind of a murder mystery and so it
and it's all real I watched the first
episode last night because you told me
to watch it and I was laughing out loud
it's the first episode real fresh to me
amazing it will but there was some
hilarious edits once you getting to know
him as a character and then it takes
that it takes some turns and it's like
it's serious oh well but it whatever
laughs okay for episode 2 episode 2 like
everything that you thought
like they're like they go a level deeper
and you're like no no no no that can't
be keep peeling it's like an onion they
keep feeling like the onion goes down
like four more layers on Episode two you
got to watch it
tiger you gotta watch it on that flip it
it's for me the thing that I was
thinking when I was watching it as I was
like man we need to find a story like
this like it was just inspirational for
me to think about I it was like over
decades yeah I know I don't know if he
was just utilizing the footage because
the guy had two cameramen falling
forever and then somebody came in and
like yeah they get into a little bit
yeah I agree
if you can't tell I agree with the wreck
okay so we're gonna be doing this for
the foreseeable future from our homes
and let us know what you thought about
this conversation and how you're dealing
with all this hashtag here biscuits will
pass tag here biscuits will be speaking
at you next week to watch more ear
biscuits click on the playlist on the
right to watch the previous episode of
your biscuits click on the playlist to
the left and don't forget to click on
the circular icon to subscribe if you
prefer to listen to this podcast it's
available on all your favorite podcast
platforms thanks for being your mythical
best
[Music]